The Legend of Zelda tears of the kingdom
is a brilliant open world game but
Publishers and developers should be
making smaller games not bigger ones
let's talk about it
Tam why are we talking about open World
Games what is the deal
we're talking about it because obviously
the Legend of Zelda tears of the Kingdom
his reviews have dropped by now this
prop is it oh no it's probably it's out
now Friday it got the elusive
illustrious the iconic 10 out of 10 on
gamespot.com as well as various other
websites except for that one you know
that one
kind of got us thinking about open world
games that we've played over the last
few years and how many of them were
actually worth our time investment you
know
um there's like been a few major
successes in that genre recently
something that really pushes the medium
forward it kind of ignites this worry
again like I don't think it's gonna
happen but I start to feel like oh
people are going to want to do these
games again now they're going to want to
try and do more open world games because
we had that phase where it was like
everyone was making an open world game
so this is a kind of like attempt to be
like hey
there is another way there has to be
another way there is first things first
we are not here to yuck anyone's yum at
all if you really enjoy playing open
world games or if you're a game designer
and you have made or you feel like you
could make an amazing open world game
then more power to you this is just
based on our observations as people who
examine Trends play a lot of these open
world games and it's kind of an
extension of the conversation we had
last week about chasing Trends but
obviously back then we were talking
about Destiny Games is acceptable stuff
now we're talking about open worlds kind
of red 4 falls into as well to a degree
it falls into the Trap that we're
talking about
so it's become clear recently I mean
this feels like pointing out the most
obvious that open world games are
overwhelming but more recently I think
it's become clear that there's a good
kind of overwhelming and a bad kind of
overwhelming so games like Ubisoft is
going to take a lot of L's in this
episode I know like when you were doing
the runner show together and you were
like listing all the games that do open
World stuff or at least have had a
negative impact in open world game
design I have gone on record and I've
called it the Uber softification yeah of
open world game design if you're a
Ubisoft developer
sorry but it is what it is your games
are still incredible games I started
Assassin's Creed Valhalla and immediate
was like no I'm not doing this I was
playing Far Cry 6 and I zoomed out the
map and you know I didn't realize you're
on an island at the beginning so I
zoomed out the map and I was like oh
that's a pretty big world then I kept
zooming out and this was an island that
was an offshoot of the main place that
was so big and so scattered with icons I
just took one look at it I just went
absolutely yeah that is the bad kind of
overwhelming the good kind of
overwhelming is Elven ring or tears of
the Kingdom it's a feeling that oh I've
got so much to do but you're excited to
do it and currently the ratio of good
overwhelming to bad overwhelming is not
in Good's favor right now for I think
for me and a lot of people open worlds
aren't particularly an exciting prospect
in the way that they used to be there's
a little bit of openable burnout it
feels like chores also on top of like
from a development perspective they are
a massive undertaking right we should
also talk about like what they represent
used to represent and what they
represent now because I think that helps
kind of frame the conversation in a lot
of ways yeah because in my mind for most
people chances are their experience of
an open world that really stuck with him
is GTA 3. yep right that was the game
that showed us what scale games could go
to in that period open World start to
become this kind of Benchmark for like
technology and development tools and and
stuff that packed powers like you if you
had a new piece of Hardware Contour the
way you showed off how powerful it is
but like look at this open world we've
made hair especially trees
look how much speed tree is doing for us
yes
open world games they also became a bit
of a flex and Gamers were interested in
that like there was a time where we were
like oh [__] open world I mean Skyrim
God Oblivion too yeah I remember seeing
those and just being like Oh my God this
is all on one discs and you got like
games that were top tier open worlds but
you also got a lot of like mid to low
tale open worlds or Publishers are
seeing that they like these open world
games let's make open world games and
that kind of I feel like that momentum
carried forward for a really long time
and I don't think we've had a weird
charge phrase I don't think we've had a
come to Jesus moment for open worlds uh
open World Games since then I mean for
spoken I think for me was the most
recent memory of very sorry I don't like
being negative but a very uninspired
open world exactly it's it's the epitome
of
people like open world games let's make
an open world game but what is it
bringing to the story what is it
bringing to the gameplay why are we
doing this so let's talk about what the
issue is here and optimal games as we've
said massive and scale scope and
possibilities
um they demand a lot of your time and
attention and can be overwhelming and
the genre I think with is fair to say is
become stagnant in a lot of ways Lucy
what was the last genuinely meaningful
evolution in the open world genre not
counting Elden ring and Zelda because
we're positing they are
look at GTA 5 and Red Dead Redemption
those are just
well done open worlds they feel you know
the whole goal is to feel lived in yeah
there's unique characters animations uh
events wherever you go within the world
if we're being reductive which
you know happy you have to occasionally
to make this kind of argument
the basic format of an open world hasn't
changed since GTA 3 like you have a map
it's probably a real place might be a
Fantasy Place Quest markers massive
space lots of people things to do most
of it fluff some of it really good the
best in the open world genre do some
aspect of that really really well so
like the story or you know the
characters The Witcher story oh
characters you know what characters
switching in GTA that was yeah but again
like mechanically I would argue that's
an execution thing that's cool like
three characters is really cool again
it's a flex like they've rendered that
entire world and you can move from one
point to the other to another character
without any sort of like issues with
that for me the thing that's made it
stand out or the last two things that I
made a standard is probably parkour from
Assassin's Creed yep and swinging in
Spider-Man the the major successes in
the genre are like Witcher 3 for writing
Elden ring for his like sense of
Discovery and bringing that from
software combat to Big space and Zelda
breath of the wild and tears of the
Kingdom for like Freedom Discovery and
creative problem solvings with the
open-ended crafting system this is gonna
sound rough and again maybe reductive
AC3 onwards like not a lot going on in
those franchise not franchise like it
grew in scale yeah and like the thing
that I look back on like what is the
most like interesting addition to AC as
a formula it's the two characters
I would have said like AC4 open world
I'd see yeah looking forward to Skull
and Bones uh whatever that comes out but
like still very close to the original
formula going to Forts discovering
places battling people at Sea yeah it's
kind of scope is is getting bigger I
would argue they're ballooning in size
interestingly the bigger those games got
the less you could use parkour which was
it's like kind of main feature and they
also changed parkour it used to be uh
you know back in ac2 it used to be very
very particular things you couldn't
couldn't climb on and then in maybe it
was Syndicate they gave you a bloody zip
line so you don't even have to climb it
and like I remember in two there was
like this thrilled jumping off a off a
roof and then holding the grab Barn
where he puts his hander as he puts his
hand out and whether you're gonna hear
or not that was cool and it had a skill
basing over time the games got bigger
more of them came out we less and less
of that and like the skill based
component almost was was gone from it so
like let's think about these various
games and how they've evolved and
whether you think is Meaningful Watch
Dogs to watch dogs Legion massive got
big got bigger got bigger complicated
and
did that really meaningfully change
anything like Legion had that cool like
anyone everywhere whatever but like that
that wasn't enough to keep me coming
back Ghost Recon advanced Warfighter 2
Ghost Recon wildlands what happened it
just got bigger and like arguably Ghost
Recon lost his identity as it went
bigger and bigger Mirror's Edge versus
Mirror's Edge Catalyst again Mirror's
Edge Catalyst a bigger game but watered
down the core mechanic of parkour and
like being able to like find lines
easily and like crafting that kind of
stuff Far Cry 3 versus Far Cry 6. like
oh yeah I mean Far Cry 3 fantastic game
yeah a very controlled experience didn't
feel too overwhelming a lot of really
cool interconnecting systems and then
Far Cry 6 just jumble of yeah it's that
ballooning and it's not just Ubisoft I
needs to take these elves like Saints
Row the latest one like there's a lot of
things that contribute to that game not
being particularly great but it's an
open world and it had nothing meaningful
to offer it was just an open world for
the sake of being an open world Hogwarts
Legacy what is the best part of Hogwarts
Legacy it's being in Hogwarts that's
what everyone says every review says
Hogwarts is great once you got out of
there it's not great yeah redfall is the
same ghostwire Tokyo for spoken for sure
yeah all right I'm gonna annoy a lot of
people Horizon I think the bar now has
been raised and the bar declare is not
does it do these things it's does it do
new things well there was that Viral
tweet going around which was uh godspeed
to every game designer who's got a
meeting with their team lead on Monday
and that's the thing that thing I hope
Tis the kingdom inspires more
interesting conversations about more
interesting takes on the open world
that's that's kind of the worry that has
led to this yeah episode where it's like
and no one not everyone can make a Zelda
maybe there is a barrel alternative
let's present it okay like scale your
games down like it sounds very reductive
and many developers are probably if
their watches are going to be like yeah
it's easy to say you know it is easy to
say we get it we don't make games we try
we just think about our games yeah we
play a lot of them and just simply go
and scale them down it's like it doesn't
consider like Market expectations and
like business it is it doesn't consider
the men in suits yeah that's a core part
of it but the idea I think like maybe
romanticized is smaller games that
deliver depth in a small space instead
of open worlds that deliver shallowness
in a big one sounds
like a straight line
it's a smaller spaces more meaningful
experiences I think of them as open
environments as opposed to open worlds
that's how they exist in my head and
these are games that are given that have
words that are given character through
scope and depth rather than their breath
out of Wilds it feels endless it feels
huge but if you put it relative to all
other Opera worlds it's very small Deus
Ex human Revolution Mass Effect 2 Yakuza
those are games that feel huge and vast
but if you think about it they're
basically interconnected hubs like
you're moving around just Hub areas but
they still feel massive right yeah and
that is kind of like the ideal like
dense smaller environment and this is
kind of like what led to the Assassin's
Creed thing where people were like okay
can you just make a smaller Assassin's
Creed no oh God I remember doing like
all the Press events for Unity and I
remember them going yeah we've recreated
Paris like I don't want to be at a scale
and I was like what do you mean I've
been to Paris I'm all right now we've
got Mirage right it's a smaller area and
that is so exciting because look at all
the power we have now look at all the
development no hand design know how we
have apply that to something much
smaller in scale where you get depth
instead of breath and that is like a
really exciting prospect we are seeing
more of these open environment games
recently like Jedi survival is
technically one of those Final Fantasy
16 is the next one to do it right
yeah and that's just a series of
interconnected hubs spoke to hayam who
went to a preview and confirmed it he
was like yeah just hubs everyone's
attention and we talked about this last
week everyone is vying for everyone
else's attention and the thing with open
World Games is when they get too
overwhelming I can easily drop off yeah
but if it is a if it is an experience
where it feels like I am making a
difference or it's interesting enough
and it is it's grab me and it is
dragging me through it because I can't
take my I physically can't peel myself
away that's what I want from another war
game I don't think the traditional model
of an open world game does that anymore
people can still make big games but the
ones that are really sticking with us
are the ones that do something
interesting beyond the traditional GTA 3
style format death surrounding massive
World by just walking through it right
like a lot of walking but like it's a
kind of introspective almost like
isolating lonely experience and that is
unique there's not nothing else like
that nothing love it I hate it nothing
else like death running exists metal
gear solid five again it's not a as
dense an open or like as a vibrant and
open world as something like GTA or
whatever but it brought stealth into an
open world genre which is hasn't been
done as good since sea of Thieves
sailing no one's done that before
Spider-Man swinging no one's done it as
good as Insomniac are doing it no man's
sky
space it's got space it does a lot of
space and it's like grown and it's
become really good yeah so the question
then becomes like is your open world as
good as The Witcher Elden ring or Zelda
or does it do something that's additive
to the genre if not maybe you should
make a smaller game so those are our
thoughts on open world games let us know
what you think about them and our
argument for smaller games in the
comments team small Games Team small
Games Team small games uh thank you so
much for watching uh obviously spot on
is part of a brand new slate of
programming we're releasing here on
Gamespot the reception has been so
lovely so if you're watching at home
thank you so much we really appreciate
it we've got stuff like no HUD how it's
saved expert reacts Firearms expert
reacts history of timeline and of course
the spot
it's packed keep watching them keep
clicking them we want to make more yeah
uh and I'm on Twitter at Lucy James
games I'm at tomorrow H and thank you
again for watching we'll see you next
time